وجد تحقيق الاستقلال
أن الحاكمة كومو تحرش جنسيًا
بالعديد من النساء ، وكثير منهن شابات من
خلال الانخراط في تعانق القبلات غير المرغوب فيها
وإبداء تعليقات غير لائقة
بالإضافة إلى مراجعة أكثر من
74000 قطعة من الأدلة
بما في ذلك وثائق رسائل البريد الإلكتروني
وملفات صوتية وصور
هذه المقابلات.  وتكشف الأدلة
عن صورة مزعجة للغاية لكنها واضحة
في المسيرة ، قلت إنه إذا
أكد التحقيق المزاعم
ضد الحاكم كومو
فعليه الاستقالة ، فهل
ستطالبه الآن بالاستقالة نظرًا لأن
المحققين قالوا إن 11 امرأة
كانت ذات مصداقية.
أنك تطالبه الآن بالاستقالة
، نعم ، وإذا لم يستقيل ، هل تعتقد
أنه يجب عزله وإقالته من
منصبه
، فلنأخذ شيئًا واحدًا في كل مرة هنا ،
وأعتقد أنه يجب أن يعتمد على
أنني أفهم أن المجلس التشريعي للولاية
قد يقرر ذلك  لا أعلم
أنني قرأت كل ذلك والحقائق مختلفة
كثيرًا
ما تم تصويره
أولاً ،
أريدك أن تعرف مني مباشرة
أنني لم ألمس أي شخص
بشكل غير
لائق أو أتقدم جنسيًا غير لائق ،
أبلغ من العمر 63 عامًا ، لقد
عشت حياتي كلها في رأي عام
وهذا ليس من
أنا وهذا هو  ليس من كنت أنت من أي وقت مضى